dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with corrosion IFA here we are
here to answer a simple question what is
peer review well in science making sure
that the validity of published results
is beyond doubt is of utmost importance
to this end many scientific journals and
conferences exist where researchers can
submit their findings in the form of a
science paper as a condition of
acceptance these papers shall undergo
extensive scrutiny by typically two to
five other scientists this refereeing
process we call peer review single blind
reviewing means that the names of the
reviewers are shrouded in mystery but
the authors of the paper are known to
them in double-blind reviews however the
papers are anonymized and none of the
parties know the names of each other
these different kinds of blind reviews
were made to eliminate possible people
related biases there's a lot of
discussion whether they do a good job at
that or not but this is what they are
for after the review if the results are
found to be correct and the reviews are
favorable enough the paper is accepted
and subsequently published in a journal
and / or presented at a conference
usually the higher the prestige of the
publication venue is the higher the
likelihood of rejection which inevitably
raises a big question how to choose the
papers that are to be accepted as we are
scientists we have to try to ensure that
the peer review is a fair and consistent
process to measure if this is the case
the nibs experiment was born nips is one
of the highest quality conferences in
machine learning with a remarkably low
acceptance ratio which typically hovers
below 25 percent this is indeed
remarkably low considering the fact that
many of the best research groups in the
world submit their finest works here so
here's the astute idea behind the nibs
experiment a large amount of papers
would be secretly disseminated to
multiple committees they would review it
without knowing about each other and we
would have a look whether they would
accept or reject the same papers
reviewing papers
and see if the results are the same if
you will at the given prescribed
acceptance ratio there was a
disagreement for fifty-seven percent of
the papers this means that one of the
committee's would accept the paper and
the other wouldn't and vice versa now to
put this number into perspective the
mathematical model of her random
committee was put together this means
that the members of this committee have
no idea what they are doing and as a
review they basically toss up a coin and
accept or reject the paper based on the
result the calculations conclude that
this random committee would have this
disagreement ratio of about seventy
seven percent this is hardly something
to be proud of the consistency of expert
reviewers is significantly closer to a
coin flip than to a hypothetical perfect
review process so experts fifty-seven
percent disagreement coin flip committee
seventy-seven percent disagreement it is
not as bad as the coin flip committee so
the question naturally arises where are
the differences well it seems that the
top ten percent of the papers are
clearly accepted by both committees the
bottom twenty-five percent of the papers
are clearly rejected this is the good
news and the bad news is that anything
in between might as well be decided with
a coin toss if the consistency of peer
review is subject to maximization we
clearly have to do something different
huge respect for the nips organizers for
doing this laborious experiment for the
reviewers who did a ton of extra work
and kudos for the fact that the
organizers were willing to release such
uncomfortable results this is very
important and is the only way of
improving our processes hopefully
someday we shall have our revenge over
the coin flip committee can we do
something about this what is a possible
solution well of course this is a large
and difficult problem for which I don't
pretend to have any perfect solutions
but there is a really interesting idea
by a renowned professor about
crowdsourcing reviews that I found to be
spectacular I leave the blog post in the
calm
section both for this and the nips
experiment and we shall have an entire
episode about this soon stay tuned
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time